When you don't have a ribber
and you want to add both knit and purl
stitches for ribbing or textured knitting
on a flatbed machine, you need
to reform individual stitches.
Now, manually reforming stitches is a bit
tedious, especially on the smaller gage
machines and fine yarn,
but the results are worth the effort.
Begin by casting on with the method
of your choice, but you'll want to choose
a method that will
stretch with your ribbing.
I've used an E-Wrap cast on.
Now, determine the stitch
pattern you want to use.
For example, you can use a one by one or
knit one, purl one stitch pattern or two
by two or any combination of knit
and purl stitches for your ribbing.
Start by knitting the desired
length of your ribbing.
You'll knit and stockinette
for the desired length of your ribbing.
Now, identify the stitch that you want
to reform and insert your latch tool
in the very bottom or the first
row that stitch on the first row.
Unravel the stitch to this point
and then re-latch each strand.
This creates a knit stitch as you're
facing the work and a purl
stitch on the opposite side.
Now, you'll want to repeat this for each
one of the stitches that you want reformed
all the way across your work.
When your whole stitch pattern has been
completed and you've reformed all
the stitches,
you just go ahead and continue knitting
your garment and your ribbing is done.